c'était une première à maurepas la ville
accueilli samedi dimanche les
championnats du monde de nunchaku un art
martial japonais issus de l'agriculture
paysanne
au programme des combats des face à face
de deux fois une minute trente et des
affrontements artistique donc la hausse
et on s'est donné le challenge de le
faire connaître dans le 78 est vraiment
le but c'est de de révéler des vocations
de te faire promouvoir ce sport là au
travers de championnat de stages
d'initiation pour que les gens
découvrent un peu l'art martial au total
l'événement réunit plus de 80
combattants de la catégorie cadets aux
vétérans venus de france de suisse du
sri lanka de thaïlande ou encore de
russie et d'angleterre
c'est de prendre du plaisir et de réunir
tous les tous les clubs qui sont
évidemment partout dans le monde aussi
on avait l'opportunité avec notre club
de venir ici et on a saisi cette
opportunité parce qu'on on aime bien se
retrouver avec nos amis les français
passer du bon temps et puis bah partager
le sport qu'on aime l'année prochaine
tous les participants se réuniront en
suisse pour ces championnats du monde de
la discipline
le pas